grüne fee is our man for this time run
he's still relevant hi I'm Nicholas be
with reason TV and today we're talking
with clay Warren he's a professor of
communication at George Washington
University also chair of the department
and he has edited a fascinating or
helped to edit a fascinating book that
is dedicated to nicolò grundig the
Danish educator who lived from 1783 to
1872 is contemporary of Soren
Kierkegaard hands Christian Andersen
he's been called the Danish Carlyle as
well as the Danish Ralph Waldo Emerson
clay let's talk about Grundig I realize
I'm mispronouncing his name Grundig has
a special place around the world
in terms of adult education in
particular lifelong learning what's the
essence of grunt vagues educational
leaders educational philosophy people
learn by talking with each other by
learning that their voice counts that
they should speak out have an opinion
and be able to say it coherently with
others in a community and a talk you
mentioned the folk high school this is a
concept that is more common in
Scandinavian countries and the German
countries what is the folk high school
that he helped pioneer it's a
residential school ideally about a
semester long where people come to
re-invent their meaning of life so it
isn't subject oriented it isn't test
oriented you don't get a degree at the
end but you get a good feeling for what
do I want to talk about with other study
learn in a democratic community and you
keep going to that I mean it's not just
something when you know between the ages
of 6 to 18 or even university level 18
to 80 or older so throughout your life
you might you know take another time in
the folk high school and to talk a
little bit about just how radical or
outside of the box this was because this
is a guy again a contemporary of
Kierkegaard and of Hans Christian
Andersen he's in 19th century Europe how
beyond what was considered normal was he
completely outside the box he was a
philosopher a religious priest in a
wider sense that what was generally
thought of as the Lutheran
minister of the time because he thought
well he actually had his own church in
copenhagen where people participated in
the service they sang their own hymns
many of which he wrote himself he was
also a poet he believed that every Dane
needed to have education and if you
think about what was going on in 1800
Europe in general many people didn't
have any education past you know a
little bit the professionals went on to
hire lap nice learning you know became
professors but most people dropped out
didn't have education so I mean there's
this incredible small D Democratic
Democratic spirit in this of that
everybody every individual has an
individual voice and an individual set
of ideas and urges or interests that
they should develop fully and then be
able to communicate yes and that was
completely radical for that time and you
actually still got breath it is so talk
a little bit about his influence in
American education because as you were
saying he hasn't really been translated
that much but he has had a powerful
impact on our concept of education
especially continuing education most
people when they go back in adult
education in America point to a fellow
fellow named Edward Linderman he wrote a
small but important book called the
meaning of adult education back in the
30s and so on most people from then on
quoted him Lindemann passed himself off
it's a complex story we don't have time
for as a Dane but he was really German
didn't want to be so people talked about
the homeland of his parents as though it
was Denmark and it wasn't he couldn't
speak Danish she couldn't read Danish
but he went back to look at the folk
high school action he loved groom fee he
heard a lot of the talk he got the
philosophy orally in hand the living
word again his groom fees the way of
being in the world brought it back to
the United States put it in his book and
so one of the things I've done when I've
looked at that in the school for life is
to model what did he say and what are
the principle tenets of American adult
education they're the same talk a little
bit about how
grunty was distinct from German
education the German education model
which was very influential especially in
the u.s. whether we're talking about
kindergarten or a kind of research
university how was what did grow in Vic
of German education and you know how
does that play out today well I thought
it was okay if you're going to be a
professor but most people wouldn't be
that so he thought it was a little
stuffy too formal it was based on dead
languages Greek and you know Latin why I
do that if you're a normal person and at
that time most were farmers yeah
that didn't mean they shouldn't have
education he was always worried you know
it wasn't just World War one in World
War two where Germany tried to take over
countries Germany for years tried to
take over Denmark he thought the only
way to really put a handle you know to
stop that is if all citizens united knew
that their country was important knew
how to speak out collective spirit and
so on is he does he anticipate maria
montessori and a kind of student based
learning experience or is you know was
there much interaction there again if
people had read his writing the answer
would be yes
Montessori is very much grown fijian as
is let's say paulo ferreira and pedagogy
of the oppressed all of this you know is
after one fee and a lot of people point
to that I mean I wrote down a few names
actually in Europe and or outside of at
least the United States and yes there
are a lot of folk high schools in
Denmark it's estimated that one out of
ten Danes at any one point is in a folk
high school amazingly enough but of
course all of Scandinavia has them in
Germany as you mentioned Japan a fellow
named Matsumae founded Tokai University
and 100 private educational institutions
in Japan gives credit to goofy spent
time goofy went to folk high schools
modeled his whole system of thinking
after that Delatour a and Philippines
leading member of the resistance during
the Marcos regime room Fijian time and
Denmark modeled his philosophy what what
is the continuing relevance or the
urgent relevance
Grundy for a 21st century America let me
stay with Europe for a moment nowadays
the lifelong learning program
established by the Europe and part
European Parliament and Council has four
schools principally for developing
countries but not only so you can apply
for a grant they call them cominius
for the lower schools Erasmus for higher
education
Grune fee for adult education and
Leonardo da Vinci for vocational
education this is just a run of two or
three years old a lot of people are
applying they're interested in trying to
ramp other people up helping them here
get the spirit and so on in the United
States probably the single most
important institution we've had a number
but for American style of being they
want a credit they want a degree what's
the bottom line it's been a little hard
but Highlander in Tennessee played a
significant role in the American rights
movement since we just had march on
Washington right uh you know we go a
couple weeks ago imagine the list of
people studying there Martin Luther King
jr. Eleanor Roosevelt Ralph Abernathy
John Lewis Pete Seeger the singer even
Rosa Parks prior to her historical
refusal to give up a seat and bus in
Alabama
all those people studied at Highlander
mm-hmm it was so active in fact the
Tennessee shut it down in 1961 too
active so what about now I mean what
what what's the most urgent message of
grown V for contemporary American
education well of course I live in a
university but that doesn't mean that
group fijian thought right does not have
relevance nowadays in fact if you think
of mooks if I have to take the most
radical thing out there for us right now
through an electronic medium so on it
would be the MOOC massive open online
education right but if you take that
down to its core philosophy it is
essentially grunt fijian mm-hmm you
don't have to have a degree to get into
it really don't have to pay for it at
the moment anyone who wants to learn can
get in there and learn it doesn't have
the living word it could have if you we
had study circles after the MOOC
experience it could be a total
graffitiing experience for the it seems
it seems that his work and his example
would offer up a lot too
you know but the charter school movement
a kind of flowering of individualized
curricula as well as this idea I mean I
guess Bill Clinton talked about it in
the 90s of lifelong learning it's it
seemed kind of sketchy then but what
essentially what he offers is a way of
continuing of not just segmenting
education off so that when you're 21
you're done unless you're going on to
grad school well to me with all of the
possible good things with electronic you
know media and so forth that we have
nowadays I mean you've seen it I've seen
it in our kids rather than go out and
pick up a soccer game outside and put on
the headset dial-up Xbox 360 and have
virtual warfare with each other applying
the rhetorical insult at the end right
right so that's grin vicki and as well
that is in a way grim fijian but let's
get them outside in action with each
other right and get to that model that
would be even better you know so I think
it's a if I may mention libertarianism
for a moment if you think about what's
going on there the emphasis on
individual liberty political freedom
voluntary Association you don't have to
love Leonard Cohen to realize that he's
your man right gruene fee is our man for
this time right he's still relevant
because he centers things on voluntary
Association on individual potential and
development right and continued
engagement with the world around that's
it all right well the book that you put
out is the school for life and that's
available on Amazon it is I want to
thank clay Warren he is the chair of the
communications department at George
Washington University and the co-editor
of school for life a book that is
dedicated to both translations of grun
Vic's work and also exploitation of its
meaning clay thanks a lot thank you Nick
for reason TV I'm Nicholas